here we go
one minute
war zone
rated
50 players
have entered average rating 17 36
time and position
both will be adjusted according to
rating
here we go
oh i hate these positions and how many
times would i have played knight f6 i
did that twice and my knight had to run
home
he's not going to run home now or at
least the queens will be off if he does
okay let's get developed i hate the this
is a terrible one to have to start out
with
did you know that
it's a terrible one i hate this
not having bishop puns is brutal
ugh
okay i gotta go after the king and here
comes that pawn
okay maybe i could get that bishop or
something the knight's gonna play there
though i gotta do this
i'm dropping stuff if i do it but i have
to try it
ah pawn takes this is hanging
or that
i'm gonna run with this
hopefully it works out somehow
oh
oh wait actually my opponent is going
into a giant think
this is good
go into the think
give me a pond
dark square
weaknesses block
the king is a fighting piece ruben fine
the king is a fighting piece
oh hit a bishop
b5
run
pawn oh that knight's gonna kill me
somehow
i think no it's not
the king is a fighter
look at him a fighting piece he's a
fighter look at him
now he's gonna run for the hills you did
your job now run home
run home quickly
quickly good job
well done
come on rooks dark squares
back to tournament
they're down on time and i was close to
holding my breath again no queen rook
that means i could release the beast
here
the beast is the blue chicken gambit
if you don't know what that is you
weren't around for many streams
you missed out that's what happens when
you uh miss out on a stream oh there
goes a night
okay time now
just watch out for time let's get my
pieces out i don't have to play well no
no no no no i wanted to take that back
because i wanted to play c4 and then
knight here
i'm going to recapture my queen i don't
want f5 to be played too soon
and if i play here i don't like the dark
square weaknesses they're
devoting a lot of time right here
let okay we're even on time now this is
good
this is good
okay let's chop
knight g2
g3
bishop c4 discovery land
discovery land
be scared dark square weaknesses as well
the king doesn't have many options
this is a problem
chop more discoveries
close
it's a pinned piece what do you do to
pin pieces you keep them pinned
and you attack them
four karuskians f7
take a night it's not pinned anymore but
okay let's just castle they don't have
any time
i could have done that i should have
done that i'm gonna do it
okay i got material now time don't let
oh more discoveries
more discoveries are in the air just
pre-move
pre-move don't let any time come off
your clock six
six six a bunch of sixes and a five
this guy again did i just play this guy
ah
these are so tough
i want my bishop puns i'd rather start
without a knight
than without both bishop puns i value
them that much
okay the last time the king was a
fighting piece they must be having
flashbacks of that
so far so the same
knight right there i'm gonna do this
move earlier actually
and if capture i can recapture oh
wait a second
wait a second i'm gonna do this now
before the bishop kills me on c4 i'm
gonna do that and now
play here
pound push and now there's gonna be this
pawn move
ooh is it scary
it's definitely scary okay i gotta do
this i gotta play against the king
okay now the knight has to leave oh but
it's leaving to a good square isn't it
no it's not i'm guarding this and this
pawn push i could grab the knight maybe
at some point bishop here if the knight
backs up i'm on the rook and stopping
knight c4 i want to hit b2 pawn push as
well
oh
b2 mate threat be scared and they're
down a lot of time
let's go here knight here i just chop
and mate
right
okay there's no mate my bishop is a
fantastic defender over here isn't he
or is he
oh
okay i think i have it still i'm on that
pawn and my queen wants to come over
here to defend stuff don't you dare make
me white
don't you dare let me happen here i
should have thrown in a check okay
anyhow back to tournament 20 12 12 12
11.
okay
somebody has four games in already
okay no queen knight i could i could
maybe deal with this instead of no uh
instead of no bishop puns let's go you
know that you know the plan you know the
drill here don't you drop that dark
square bishop
oh
okay can i get the open f file
let's keep it closed
let's keep it closed f5 is going to be
happening or c5
all right let's get this in actually
maybe i want to do that
uh oh f5 they're scared they should be
scared
light squares
let's go queen why'd i do that the
knight's going to kill me right here oh
it's going to be a killer run king
kill the queen
i don't know what i'm doing
come on discoveries
discoveries discoveries where are you
where's the queen gonna go where are you
gonna go queen anywhere pawn push and
then knight here
get out of there queen
oh i got the knight i got the knight
oh that's what you get for tying your
pieces down to the defense of the night
oh i got the queen
they think there was a night fork sorry
i got loud right there that happens back
to tournament
don't be wearing headphones
get rid of the headphones
whoa i've never played this before this
is an advanced oh
this is advanced what queen h5
that could have been scary actually
oh what do i have can i have um an
f-file attack against white now
they're going to kill me they're going
to kill me for thinking in that
direction
defend like a champ
defend like a champ pawn push i gotta do
this
this knight you need to go somewhere
else i cannot deal with you you need to
go elsewhere
ugh defend bishop i want to get my
knight to d4 my knight to f5 first oh
the bishop is cooked cooked bishop i
don't want the knight to exchange
or the bishop to exchange you know what
i meant
um
pin a knight
killa knight trap of bishop it's
happening soon that's why i went home by
night
oh
he's not too good for his home here we
go b5
oh
okay
let's chop that knight up oh they're
gonna just take my knight no they're not
they're gonna fork and get this pond
i can still get their bishop though or
this pond and a fork maybe
got a fork i think everything's okay
smooth sailing from here it might be
smooth sailing
take the queen
take the rook
and get the bishop finally
time situation is good too
oh tricky tricky tricky pinaroosky i'm
on the bishop still there's no rush get
out of the tricks
grab a rook
grab a bishop and finally develop
no time left
just take my bishop i was in free move
take if i'm in pre-move like that
oh watch out for tricks
right here
checks
where the checks
where the checks where the checks then
why are they moving so fast why are they
moving so fast run pun
run
you know you want to run
okay wow they were flying
30 no 42 30. somebody has six games in
let's go no queen rook aussie viper
oh
blue chicken
gambit
okay let's roll here bishop g2
let's go thunderhorse variation
this is known as the thunderhorse
variation now
get out of there knight i want to be
here
pawn push pawn push again king side
assault
assault
hit a bishop oh it's just going to come
here and get my night i should have just
grabbed this pond oh they're giving me
material hit the knight grab mate over
here
grab mate what are you talking about i'm
grabbing the knight though
i'm on g7 soon
move night
anywhere anywhere night i want to
deflect that knight
yes he went voluntarily wonderful 42
42 42 i'm up there six games
out of six so
none of this again okay come on out
night
can i get this f file working
get out of there night
just capture my knight
oh they're not doing that
okay
uh-oh uh-oh what do i have here
quick mate this is difficult now
difficult to defend oh don't you dare
don't you dare get my queen don't you
dare get my bishop okay i'm gonna give
it up but just so i could get
get out of there knight oh what a pain
i want my bishop right where
i want my knight here i think
let's do it no no no no right here i
want to get to f3
and i want to target this guy right here
and actually right here i should have
done that is the queen dead the queen
might be dead there might be made here
though
oh they dropped their rook
oh
they're feeling pressure checkmate
king goes to f1 it's mate
oh pigs pigs pigs
give a check
where's the mate
check come on knight deliver a mate
we've a mate
we've a mate it's happening
unavoidable
mate in two
look right here there's only one defense
rook right here they're going to let
their clock tick don't you dare yes back
to tournament 56 56 i'm gonna tie
56 56 28 26
18 minutes left
oh
okay i gotta go after that f-pawn real
quick
i gotta hang on to that i can't give
that center up
okay dark square bishop i guess uh okay
queen come over here and defend gotta
get rid of that knight i think
um
let's play here or here here right here
just do something
anything
bishop come out ah
okay now i'm going to take the night now
why now i don't know now
why now
oh man
just just take my pond quickly this one
so i could castle oh not that one
oh man
i need help
i'm not getting help
oh queen takes b is good just take my
pawn please i just want a castle
they're going to push
i have a good square f6
they're checking me now my king is
running for the hills he's running for
the hills
bishop
oh oh oh oh oh this is a problem
i gotta defend that pawn
oh i want to get my queen right here
please let me get it there is this
working oh it's not working
come on come on come on come on i want
queen h6
can i get this working it's not working
the queen is there get out of there
queen
get out of there queen please just go
somewhere else
oh anywhere else please
oh i gotta do that i only have five
seconds i don't have any time oh this is
painful
no don't you dare try to trade
no
get away from me or i do to deserve this
oh i could have just taken the queen it
was a free queen
oh they were just pre-moving
oh i don't have any time no time no time
no time i can't win
oh
oh i'm down on time
oh i want to cry
man
ah could i have done better somebody has
nine out of nine 16 minutes left
that's it i'm getting this i'm coming
back swinging
don't you dare count me out
who's counting me out
no queen knight you could do it that's
okay you don't need the queen night do
you
or do you
oh this is tough this is tough tough
tough tough
let's go kick a night away
get out of there night
and
oh it's a trap night that's happened
before the night has to go here give me
a pond give me the pond at least
they're not gonna take the night okay
they are
oh it's a free bishop and i'm targeting
f2 next f2 is under heavy fire
heavy fire
let's keep it closed
my light square bishop wants to do
something else then bite at a rock i
promise you that
he wants to do something other than bite
at that d5 pond it's stupid for as long
as it's there
oh they're shuffling
they're shuffling
oh every day
every day they're shuffling oh i don't
have enough support for that pawn push a
couple times actually
just sack that pawn i want him to take
it
oh trouble big trouble
right here i need a castle no i don't
let's give a check
with the pawn push his queen over here
over here mate mate mate mate soon
where's the mate
no trade don't you dare me one or two
i got a rook at least
what's the time situation deflection
got the queen
this mate
don't run away
don't run away is this mate where are
you going where are you going
get over here
making two one no stalemate two you can
make a pound move anything just go
resign
quick
wow is he flying away 101
70 68 62 13 minutes left
who is this
who why isn't anybody knocking out that
guy
oh this one again is this the guy that i
lost to gonzo got me
so many
oh man i think bishop takes knight was
available
uh oh not here i gotta get that get rid
of that bishop
um i'm gonna do something weird i wanna
get that dark square bishop
get out of there
get out
okay
now take my knight
let me get some play against f7 please
watch over this there might be night
here or not let's come over here get out
of checking range
there might be night check here one day
one day uh grab the knight hit f7 get
this h rook doing something first light
square weaknesses f7 is hit a bunch of
times and it's not defended
there goes a knight
check right here
and then and then uh do what actually
i'm going to block
and then take that knight out
i want to get rid of that knight let's
do this first i want to make uh some
files opened first take this and then a
key move something i saw first in a
protrusion game a way to keep uh
oh
ooh i have this covered it's a bit scary
though oh i made it i made it i made it
no i'm not
i thought queen to g3 was there i had
king to h1
okay let's come over here i think
everything is okay now
after that little scare or a big scare
you you call it what was it was that a
big scare
oh give me the queen where's the queen
when you need the queen
where is the king going
oh
he is scared
real check one of those two they
resigned back to tournament 121 somebody
knocked that guy off
or quick resigned to me
let's go
bishop b7
bishop g7
v and kettle land
and
let's try and close it up
or what
okay they're burning time here
their clock is a ticking
there may okay get out of there there
might be a sack here no i haven't
defended with my knight
then my the knight might come here i
think i'm going to take it then push if
that happens
oh i'm going to take the queen if it
comes there
and the knight if it doesn't move
and it wasn't moving grab a pawn
grab another pawn hit h2
uh oh are they going to resign here i'm
on h2 and b2
oh my pawn is going nuts
four karooskies
grab another piece
h2
um
he's defended and now knight e5
okay i'm in a pin but i could take the
rook or the bishop or give a check on c5
to get out of it
that's not really check is it
um
just go here i don't want stuff to
happen against f7
and if pawn push here i'm just gonna
allow that knight to die
um
let's go rook
okay clock count is good
um being tricky rook takes pawn
capture towards the center let's have a
good reason not to
rook takes pawn
pins pin on the bishop
uh oh
could take with the fork to follow
forks
pins
skewers
down on time 161 116 108. oh it's going
to be a struggle just to get top three
exactly 10 minutes left why'd i do that
move
i meant g3
uh
okay i gotta now i can't okay i could do
this
i couldn't play h3 there because there
was pressure on this okay let's get my
knight to f5
i make that happen my bishop wants to
come over here
my queen wants to get to h6
oh be scared
h5
coming up
uh oh
is this trouble it might be
oh
there's trouble here
there's trouble
h
h you know it
main two threat
i have that defender my bishop no wait
wait wait that's just me that was a
quick win back to tournament 128 let me
have 181.
whoa okay i'm in second i almost missed
that mate right there i was already on
that square with my knight okay good
uh it seems like second might be the
best hope right here the best chance
second place
is first place even possible
okay can i get these little guys in oh
i should have done that
now or never
oh i just dropped a pawn
that's all right
you could do it
oh man
oh man
oh man i gotta run i gotta run i gotta
run
i'm not gonna be able to run
uh the queens are gonna come off
oh why didn't they go after the c7 pawn
i was really scared about that
okay they should still go after it
okay now they're in trouble maybe their
night gets trapped somehow
ah i got their knight but they got my
knight
oh i don't want to drop that pawn
let me guard it with my bishop
and then maybe trap the queen somehow
get out of there queen
if you go here
oh it's a free queen i'm gonna take the
free queens
go after the knight
let's go i have this i have it
let's go pun
cramper
that's a cramping move dark square
weaknesses guess where my queen wants to
be
over here
here not so fast okay oh check
pre-move that
not this one
okay pawns are falling everywhere
let's grab this guy give a check next
right here with check
and check here and then pawn push even
though there could be rook takes or
something king f6
i think everything is nice and cozy
what's the clock situation
just pre move not gonna finish it's not
gonna finish
not gonna finish back to tournament 148
140.
201 is in first
is it even worthwhile to read that one
off
no queen rook
i don't think i've ever had a game where
ah
what am i trying to say where i have uh
where there's
it's been even material there's always
been something
something wrong
okay i gotta come here because i wanna
get this move in i think
um i'm gonna throw this h-pawn down
you could do some damage can he
okay let's come in this direction since
they're castled
kick that knight away
play pawn push if this
pun push here pawn push here
keep it closed basically here we go
bishop shut down the bishop shut down i
have open b file
okay how can i make use of it get my
night working watch over this square
with the bishop
and okay i gotta no i don't want to take
that knight the bishop comes to life
what is my rook in the corner doing he's
stupid
look at that rook
rook you're gonna do something weird
look up and then over
oh it's opening up and i don't want it
to open up
what's my night doing what's the clock
situation
i want to get that bishop
just take my rook
please
probably good but i just want him out of
my uh territory here he's just a pain
i gotta go with this i'm gonna go with
this i don't want the coin i don't want
the queens on the board the position is
going to blow open here i have to get
off of this file and hope for the best
i'm down to full rook aren't i
are two exchanges or a rook and exchange
one of the two give a check time burners
go with the time burners when in doubt
time burn when in doubt undermine
give a check
what's my bishop doing do something else
over here ah free night pre-move grab a
night this might be close to uh
better actually somehow back to
tournament 168.
221 168 that guy has 16 out of 16 less
than five
you need a couple quick resigners and
they're
probably not gonna happen are they
okay can i get this in
okay
over here
i have the file to work with
can i get this
um
oh i'm on h3
hang on my bishop is ready to be trapped
okay oh
i think pawn push and i would have been
in trouble
i'm on c4
give me that bishop please i want my
dark square bishops doing something
let's defend the knight
all right let's take the dark square
bishop
over here there's checks available
bishop over here with check
and then this and then i'm on this
square e4
i think it's actually turning out to be
decent here
um
okay now i gotta watch out for what
a little scary a little bit scary
oh or a lot scary oh man no it's not i
have a check oh this is probably mate
somehow
yeah this is big trouble now for white
or is it there might be something like
uh
oh
i think i need to do
oh man
oh man
i gotta i gotta defend what am i doing i
wasted so much time
oh
man
oh this is what i was fearing
can i hit him with a fork
discover checks oh i have this covered i
think i have it okay i could take here
discovered tricks discovered tricks i
got the queen
oh
i got the queenie no i got mate
wait wait wait wait where's the mate
okay take here mate with the bishop
soon bishop's bishop f2 i don't have any
time
where's the time where's the time
where's the time dances mate oh they
should have went somewhere else that was
me
oh i didn't know if i was going to be
able to get that one if he went
somewhere else
i couldn't name the square it's just he
had to go somewhere else i think
besides that
what is that bishop up to
get that bishop can i get him
nope
okay oh i'm gonna get a7 maybe
get something
give a check
oh i got the queen the queen is dead
that's what happens when the knight goes
to the edge night on the rim is very
grim in that case
very grim night i should have just
pushed let's castle because it's okay to
do that once you get your material back
now what's the clock count
don't you dare get into a time struggle
here
let's go c4 open up the position but not
so fast knight forks watch out for him
upon push
open
oh there goes a bishop
and there goes a pawn
right
pre-move
let's come here forks forks forks forks
check
development forks
more checks rook on an open file my
knight is dead but my bishop comes to
life i'm looking for pawn push aren't i
that pawn is fast he's passed
fast and passed
give a check i should take him to rook
too that would have been decent let's do
it now
and then take this guy
and then take the pawn how many times
did i have that available that was there
for a while wasn't it get out there
knight remove the defender of the pun
okay now check and then i could pre-move
this there's probably a pin and there is
oh this is tough more pins
grab a rook give a check mate in two
no time just move anything go go go go
go do not let your clock tick back to
tournament 291 212 208 49 48. i need a
quick resigner quick resigner
quick resigner it's a quick resigner
that's what i needed that was clutch 228
to 12. quick resigner again am i getting
another quick resigner
no this is not a quick resigner i got to
do something drastic give pawns up go
after f7
push upon here
push the knight around
kill the knight if he goes to the center
get out of there night
kill the knight
bishop here
bishop here just take my pawn just take
my pawn i want there's only 15 seconds
don't burn your clock
resign
there's only 10 seconds
yes a quick resigner back to tournament
248.
five four three
two
one
another quick resigner 258
man i was getting showered with points
right there at the end it wasn't enough
to get that guy 311.
second place
confetti i will take it that guy was on
a mad terror right there 20 out of 20.
ah
how do you catch somebody who's 20 out
of 20
good games all
quick resigners everywhere
all right
wow
i shouldn't say thank you to the quick
resigners because then more will be
doing that and then i'll be getting
accused of cheating and stuff
these people aren't being paid off with
cubits
don't even start letting that be
entering your thought process
oh man
what a tough tournament